at what point or was there a point where
things kind of got
sketchy or where to you're at the point
where you're thinking in your head like
this might be a little bit too good to
be true like i gotta start watching my
back a little bit more like
this it can't be this i can't be right
this gravy train's not gonna last
forever
yeah at what point did [ __ ] start to get
go sideways
um
well my original plan was to to just
sell them to drug dealers basically
but ultimately i had a drug habit at the
time as well
so a lot a lot of it was ripping off
drug dealers you know buying the heroin
with it you know so
um most
most of the guys i like i'd get one drug
dealer for
you know spend 500 bucks 500 bucks a
thousand bucks you know until it kind of
stacked up to where i got this guy for
you know 10 grand five grand something
like that
um and usually the the guys weren't even
mad if they did find out because they
were able to i mean it was like right
yeah they could go re-up they went to
the store
um so a lot of the guys if they did find
out they were just like holy [ __ ] you
got me like you know what i mean good
job and now they wanted to buy them from
me because
now they knew that they were fake they'd
be like well if you're gonna buy that's
a weird thing right it's kind of like
you screwed me but i didn't get screwed
yeah they respect the game yeah they
chalk it up as loss but they didn't
really lose anything so they were just
you know impressed they were like oh
[ __ ] you made these all right keep
selling them to me or you know
maybe like i'd keep buying heroin from
them but instead of giving them a
hundred dollars for a gram i'd give them
four hundred dollars for a gram because
they knew it was fake now you know so
kind of just do that and if if
see in in knoxville most of the the drug
dealers are from out of town like people
from detroit and cleveland chicago
atlanta all go to knoxville why's that
i think like bigger cities like detroit
it seems like there's lots of drug
dealers there you know what i mean so
they just kind of branch out and go to
these mid-level cities you know i mean
knoxville is not big but it's not small
there's money there there's a lot of
drug addicts there so you've got a lot
of people from out of town like it's
known in knoxville that detroit boys is
what everybody calls them detroit boys
because it's just a group a large group
of people from flint michigan detroit
michigan
um and i was doing business with a lot
of a lot of those guys
yeah i mean tennessee's known for being
like there's so many there's so many
like oxy documentaries
yeah in tennessee it's crazy like just
just the like the opioid epidemic ripped
through tennessee yeah it's heroin now
it's straight up heroin it's fentanyl
fentanyl really yeah people purposely
taking fentanyl oh yeah for sure really
i mean there are still people that kind
of deny its existence you know no this
is real heroin but it's all i mean
it's all real or it's all fit the crazy
thing now that people are talking about
is like people that are they say people
that buy cocaine are accidentally
overdosing on fentanyl
but i saw like a like it seems like a
weird thing because
[Music]
fentanyl is the opposite of cocaine yeah
right so if somebody's
overdosing on fentanyl and they're
buying cocaine
it seems like it would be
counterintuitive to the person that's
selling that cocaine yeah i agree i'm
not sure if there's i mean obviously
there's cases where people overdose like
you're not going to cut cocaine with
fentanyl no well your customers
obviously aren't going to like that the
only reason i could think of is either a
because fentanyl is physically addictive
they might add a little bit in to get
people like physically hooked on it or
or i mean fentanyl is so potent that
like literally a tiny like if you had
fentanyl in a ziploc bag right and you
poured it out to make your heroin or
whatever and there was even residue left
in that bag if you then put cocaine in
that bag there's still enough fentanyl
to hurt someone that doesn't have a
tolerance to it right you know that's
what i'm saying it would make more sense
that like if say some a drug dealer was
selling because i know that they cut
heroin with fentanyl right yeah so if
like a drug that has sold heroin ansel
coke maybe they cut it up on the same
table and a little bit of fentanyl
accidentally got into the cocaine that
would make sense yeah they would never
purposely you got to think people who
are cutting
heroin with fentanyl are probably
cutting their coke too
with something like creatine or inositol
or something so if they use the same
blender to to mix up their products or
you know i'm sure there's cases like
that but everything's circumstantial you
know what i mean i'm sure i'm sure
there's probably are people that do
purposefully throw fentanyl in it just
uh who knows you know
but
i think it's different cases for you
know everybody just
[ __ ] happens
so people are are really [ __ ] up on
fentanyl in tennessee right now yeah
meth meth and heroin well they say like
i said they say heroin it's really it's
mostly fentanyl everything i've seen
it's like just plain white powder which
isn't heroin you know but yeah it's
it's pretty bad in knoxville meth too
meth is a
big one
really oh yeah
when did fentanyl start becoming a big
thing out there
um well i guess i'm from tampa so i mean
i
the last eight years i've lived in
knoxville and when i when i first moved
there it was still like pills like roxy
yeah
um but they they just got too expensive
so i mean i'd say i started noticing
uh fentanyl probably five six years ago
you know
but it's like i mean they say it's like
ten times more potent than morphine
right oh it's more than that more than
10 times well there's different kinds
too there's like fentanyl car fentanyl
and then there's other designer you know
you four seven seven zero zero which is
like just you know random designer drugs
but yeah they're super strong opiates
nowadays they make making china and ship
over here and
but knoxville is bad like if you walk to
a gas station you'll probably have
one or two people pull up and offer you
heroin really yeah
yeah so that i mean that i was good
as far as
having counterfeit money strangers come
up to you and offer to sell you drugs of
course you're gonna you'll buy some and
give them fake money yeah you know what
i mean right for sure especially if
you're gonna see him again right yeah
well i mean i try to keep doing business
with them but there was also like
sketchy points when you know you wonder
if they did find out if they're pissed
off you don't want to call them the next
day to buy more
if they found out so you really have to
you know read people over the phone
like i said in my case luckily most
people uh
you know weren't angry
you know i mean right there was one guy
that the guy that actually ultimately
set me up and with the the feds
when i first met him i was
uh basically like my roommate uh
roommate this girl uh was getting heroin
from him
uh you know with my money
and uh we got him for probably i'd say
close to 10 grand over the course of
like a few weeks or something
and i guess he's uh one of his the bills
was in his pocket and it was raining so
that that color shifting the makeup that
i paint on wiped off because it got wet
so he ultimately found out that the
bills were fake
um
and i i pulled in my driveway one day
and he was standing in my driveway like
yelling at my roommate so i'm like oh
[ __ ] this is gonna be a problem you know
i mean um but he didn't know that they
were coming from me he was because she
was the one getting it so i just walk by
and hear him yell and you know he's like
i don't care i'm not mad i just want to
know where the [ __ ] you got him from you
know what i mean so when i heard that i
you know i started selling them to them
you know what i mean i basically said
like listen they're coming from me
you know i'll sell them to you for you
know 20 25 cents on the dollar
so he was buying
anywhere from five ten thousand dollars
worth every time he'd go up to cleveland
to to re-up like he'd go and pick up a
brick a kilo of heroin or whatever
usually cut it to two but nonetheless
he'd
want at least like 10 grand worth of my
bills to mix in with you know
his real money
really
so he would give you 10 grand and you
would give him 40 grand
no i never did that much it was more
like i'd give him 10 and he'd give me
2500. oh okay i mean i had multiple
different people that i was doing those
kind of deals with yeah um
but
you know he'd normally buy like a brick
at a time so you know if he was spending
40 grand he'd want 10 maybe 15 000 of my
money to mix in with it you know i mean
so we were mixing in this fake money
with real money
so there i mean it's hard to it's
you couldn't tell that the bills were
fake if i handed you one and told you
they were fake let alone mixing it in
with you know forty thousand dollars of
other real money and just mix it in
randomly yeah and so
i had a
couple different like a group of a
couple different guys from cleveland
probably about five different guys uh
from detroit um a couple guys from
atlanta
and then you know there's random other
people that were from knoxville but
you know so
i